back everyone the brand new centennial  bowl flyover bridge open to drivers just  a few minutes ago at noon  it is the state's second longest bridge  look at it and it's about  seven football fields end to end this  flyover will connect northbound 95  with westbound 215 the beltway in  northwest las vegas  right now people have to use surface  streets and lights to get from one end  to the other  we're tracking roughly a hundred  thousand vehicles daily  on these ramps here at us-95 and 215  beltway in northwest  and that's only expected to grow in the  future yes and now drivers don't have to  use those to go from both ends because  the bridge  is open but the entire 73 million dollar  centennial bowl project  well that's not done quite yet the  finishing touches are expected to be  done  in mid-december and nate follows that  every week so just stay with us for  updates on that